qui ancrait qu ils sont sur mars sur la
lune en orbite autour de la terre ils
planifient de se rendre jusqu'à jupiter
les chinois sont partout dans l'espace
et il vise toutes les cibles
c'est très impressionnant c'est or une
grande démonstration de capacités
technologies c'est une façon je dirais
de démontrer qu'ils sont une grande
puissance leur prime est extrêmement
agressifs et donc les étapes se
déroulent beaucoup plus rapidement que
par exemple le programme spatial
américain
depuis leur premier vol spatial en 1999
la chine à ligny succès premier vol
habité une sonde lunaire un mini
laboratoire spatial et bien sûr en 2021
le début d'une station orbitale et la
mission martienne
même bill nelson le nouveau patron de la
nasa l'admet le rover chinois est une
grande réussite qui fait de l'ombre à la
nasa et comité sénatorial américain
conclut qu' aujourd'hui la chine est
devenue une puissance spatiale une
puissance capable de réaliser des
percées technologiques majeures il
faudrait qu avec ces énormes moyens
financiers c'est résoudre satellite et
ses quatre sites de lancement la chaîne
a tous les outils en main depuis trois
ans c'est aussi le pays le plus actif
dans l'espace avec 112 lancement
l'europe n'est plus le deuxième
puissance spatiale la russie n'est plus
depuis ce temps la chine a pris la 7e
place lors malgré tout le programme
spatial chinois encore des étapes à
franchir
essentiellement ce qu'ils font c'est
calquer ce qui a déjà été fait ce n'est
pas mauvais en soi il ya de la science
très intéressante à faire et c'est tout
à fait légitime mais ils ont pas produit
ou très très peu ils ont pas réussi
d'exploit qui sont uniques
l'agent spécial chinoise a aussi une
forte tendance à travailler en vase clos
les chinois font cavalier seul je dirais
que financièrement ils en ont les moyens
mais peut-être qu'à terme il y aura une
forme de collaboration
il faut dire que pour des raisons
politiques et stratégiques
les américains refusent l'accès à la
station spatiale internationale ou
chinois
et pénalise les états qui partagent de
la technologie spatiale avec eux
collaborer avec la chine c'est se mettre
en porte à faux avec washington
mais le nombre d'agents spatiale dans le
monde en augmente et certains pays se
disent que il obtenons plus en
collaborant avec la chine
washington un instinct éventuellement
des astronautes de pays amis dans
l'espace la chine augmentera aussi sa
sphère d influence et mercredi d'autres
points dans la nouvelle course à
l'espace
d'abord l'objectif de l'est la chine a
été de rattraper tout le monde puis
égalé tout le monde dépasser tout le
monde s'arrête avions ici norma grondin
radio-canada mauvaise